une situation qui se répète chaque matin
des voitures au ralenti à la sortie de
nos repas pour rejoindre la gare de la
verrière où la n10 bientôt une ancienne
histoire
le pont actuel qui est derrière nous va
être réhabilité bien évidemment ce sera
là la dernière phase
il va être doublée sur la partie donc
sur la sur la gauche par un pont
métallique qui va être en paix sur le
balan en prs en profil reconstituer
soudé et ce sera la partie qui sera
affecté au tcsp le transport en commun
en site propre qui permettra cette
cupidité du trafic et enfin au but
d'arriver à l'heure de façon tout à fait
régulière
la pose du pont se fera elle de nuit
modifiant la circulation de la n10 sur
une voie entre février et septembre les
véhicules des particuliers conserveront
les deux voies actuelles de septembre à
fin avril 2018
donc ça va être les aménagements delà du
pont lui-même de façon à préparer le
basculement de la circulation sur
l'autre côté là ça va nous emmener pour
un bon moment il ya beaucoup de beaucoup
de travaux à faire de réfection de
chaussée les aménagements verront aussi
la création de pistes cyclables et une
voix vaulion directement le boulevard
guy schuller et la rue lui lormand est
d'un coût de plus de 9 millions d'euros
ces travaux sont en partie financés par
l'état la région et le département
ils prendront fin en décembre 2018